foreign
[Music]
this site certificate is not trusted
anymore when loading a website are you
the user on the back end that manages CA
certificates and worry about making sure
they are rotated before they expire or
do you worry about your Cas being
compromised and putting your information
at risk when you find yourself in a
situation with a compromised or expired
CA it's crucial that this is quickly
dealt with if you're not able to quickly
set up your new ca properly and make
sure that it works before deleting the
old one you risk having users run into
outages or be unable to react to a
compromise in time even though this is
such an important piece of working with
certificates CA rotation is typically a
complex and error-prone process it
involves moving multiple Parts like
distribution of your trust anchor the
group of root CA certificates installed
to establish trust and requires careful
orchestration of going from one CA to
another safely that is where C a pools
from certificate Authority service come
in
CA pools allow you to Simply and safely
rotate your Cas without downtime or
changes that need to be deployed a
certificate Authority CA pool is a
collection of multiple Cas with a common
certificate issuance policy and IAM
policy in other words a CA pool
represents a single certificate issuance
endpoint for multiple Cas this
characteristic is important because it's
what allows rotation to occur without
any changes from the client's
perspective CA pools provide the ability
to rotate trust chains without any
outage or downtime for their payloads
you can create a new ca without
affecting your issuance path and test it
in the stage State before you enable it
to replace the expired or compromised CA
this ensures seamless CA rotation and is
essential to avoid service downtime and
remain protected in compromise scenarios
typically you'd need to roll out a
configuration and tell your workloads to
look in a new place for the new trusted
CA thanks to the way we designed our CA
pools API we've cut out these steps
there are two key things in the design
that have allowed us to do that first a
single certificate issuance endpoint
which I mentioned before and a single CA
certificate retrieval endpoint by having
a single retrieval endpoint rotation
becomes much simpler because there's
only one place to go for the necessary
information to rotate as long as you
integrate with this endpoint once you
won't have to change any configuration
or code to get the new ca certs
you can simply run a few commands to
rotate the CA and we take care of the
rest on the back end without any effects
to your workloads
there are a lot of guardrails in place
to make this possible you can enable
both Cas at the same time and make sure
everything runs well before disabling
and eventually deleting the old one
plus it's easy to roll back if anything
does go wrong because of this CA State
management process it's important to
keep in mind that this process is
dependent on each client application
regularly fetching the latest trust
anchor from the ca pool so you'll need
to be mindful about making sure your
workloads have gotten access to Cas and
have pulled the new ca trust anchor
before rotating rotating your Cas with
CA pools is a safe procedure for
introducing a new ca testing it rolling
it out and being able to roll it back
safely if need be helping to ensure that
your certificates don't expire or become
compromised it can save you large
amounts of downtime with no necessary
deployment changes decreasing risk and
time spent with engineering resources to
execute rotation
check out the links in the description
for tutorials on how to create manage
the rotation of update and delete a CA
pool thanks for watching
[Music]